i want to talk a little bit about one of
the quirkier ideas in in signal
processing and that's the idea of
negative frequency
this is a phrase that may not initially
make any sense at all what's what does
it mean to be a negative frequency um
could there be a sine wave that goes
up and down at a at a rate of
minus 10 cycles per second what what on
earth does that mean
or could there be a a radio station of
minus 680 kilohertz
what is that that doesn't sound like it
means anything
there is a sense in which negative
frequency
is understandable and we're going to
just quickly talk about that here
you remember we can describe a cosine
like this cosine
of omega t
equals one half
e to the plus
j omega t
plus
e to the minus j omega t
and each of these components each of
these complex exponentials here
we can draw as a rotating complex number
so for this first one we could actually
draw it if we wanted to we could draw it
like this we could draw
a complex number out here in space and
think of it as a a rotating vector
and that would be e
to the j omega t
this one has a plus sign
now the other thing
this term over here
would look like
a similar thing it'd be some
vector in space
there's that number right there
e to the minus j omega t
and this one rotating in the negative
direction so that's means
this is rotating this way
so the idea of a negative frequency when
we talk about rotating vectors makes
makes good sense if we are rotating in
the positive direction like this
you could say that's a positive
frequency and if we're rotating in the
negative direction
like this
you could say that's a negative
frequency
so omega t
gives us the speed and this sign right
here and this sign right here give us
the direction the the frequency here is
plus omega t
and the frequency here
is minus omega t
so in this sense of rotating vectors
negative frequency seems like a pretty
simple idea
okay so let's go where it's not a simple
idea and that's when we do this thing we
did before where we projected
where we projected these vectors onto a
cosine wave and spread out the time axis
linearly like this going down the page
for the cosine
remember we we did this we we drew a
line here
on this side we're going to do plus
omega t so we're going to plot e
to the plus
j omega t here
this will be the real axis
this will be the imaginary axis
and down here this will be the voltage
axis and this will be the time axis
so when we start out at time equals zero
we have we projected down here
and we got that value right there
and then as time goes on if we tip
our arrow up like that to that point
then we project
down to the cosine curve right here
if we let our arrow go all the way to
the other side
it projects like this down
it projects down to this point on the
cosine curve and as we go farther and
farther let's go straight down for a
second that one projects to right
there
and then as we come over here
it projects
to that point right there
and eventually when we get back to home
again we get back to zero the projection
is right to this point here
and so we've with one rotation we've
carved out one
cycle of the cosine
so that seems pretty clear omega t is
there omega t is down here
okay so let's do it again but this time
we'll we'll go over on this side
and we'll
we'll plot
e to the minus j omega t
all right and so this again is the real
axis and this is the imaginary
and this is the voltage axis and this is
the time axis
so let's start out again we're going
straight sideways at time equals zero so
let's project that down
and
okay that's pretty good that's the same
as before we got the same v here
now let's tip it down let's say we
rotate this way a little bit
and here's our new position of our
vector
and that projection after a little bit
of time it goes to right here
and then if we go over this way
eventually
rotate some more
we'll project
to this point here
and when we're straight sideways
it'll project
to this peak right here
and you can see what's happening is
basically the exact same thing is
happening as happened on the left
which is
these points carve out a cosine wave
just as we'd expect
and when this vector gets all the way
back around
to zero we've done one cycle we're back
home
and now we're projecting to this point
here
what happened here
is we took two different vectors
rotating in opposite directions this one
clearly had a positive frequency because
it was going
counterclockwise
this one had a negative frequency
because it's going clockwise
and both of them carved out the exact
same cosine wave when we got done
so in the in the vector world where
we're spinning vectors around it seems
very natural to talk about plus and
minus frequency but when we cast this
back into say a real world
v of t
notice that the idea of negative
frequency just sort of it melts away it
evaporates it's not it's not really
there anymore and it's been removed by
this process of projection so when the
idea of negative frequency comes up and
it seems like it doesn't make sense in
this time domain view of the of the
signals but then just remember that when
we go back up here and we look at the
rotating vectors that it just means
which way the vector's spinning